pairings and Fantastic action and we
have LIF off Magnus with white decided
to go with E4 pretty much all the way
with some exceptions in this rap and
Blitz we've seen him have different
approaches over the years playing some
London systems or whatever wow H3
against the Petro why did you tell us
magnos all these World Championship
matches we were looking for ways against
the Petro he never told us about AG
three wow he kept it in the pocket for
the right time and the time has come
against okay he's just trying to get out
of the book here as quickly as possible
y Yang G does not look impressed puts
the on D6 I'm sure could have gone to F6
as
well
yeah the game yeah and and N slow down
he clearly is surprised and he
challenges that Knight on D6 with C4
it's a very thematic typical
idea now you he has a decision to take
do you go Bishop E6 what do he do yeah
it's not easy I'm not happy with this
Knight D6 choice at
alling so much easier yeah then you know
your next move Bishop E7 short
Castle yeah he sacrifices the pawn on D5
he goes Bishop B7 take it CD Knight C3
look a bit like these POF positions
where black gives that pawn but looks
like a good version for white just
keeping that pawn for now KN on D6
stupid why not yeah takes Knight C3
eventually D4 Bishop F4 Bishop E2 short
Castle all the moves will be played
automatically yeah that's how easy it is
you play H3 then you take the D5 ball
you take it and you win against the
pet wow okay it also shows that the
players are very tired so coming up with
some surprise getting your opponent out
of his balance his comfort zone but yuan
is fighting he's going for B5
clearly aiming for Bishop B7 eventually
A5 B4 hitting that D5 Pawn Yeah but
white plays D4 also asking the B5 Pawn
about its intentions so you yet to go A6
stopping his counterplay on the queen
side I don't like any of this bishop D3
I guess he wants Knight D7 Knight B6 but
looks yeah but surprisingly Magnus
played Bishop E2 I was also thinking
like Bishop DC but Knight E5 Bishop F3
also Lal yeah yes that's the setup
Magnus has in mind uh reinforcing the D5
X the pawn the C6 queres
there unb everything Knight B Bishop F I
played Bishop F6 so right he played
Bishop F6 I was wondering that did white
ever have such a good position against
the Petrov in 10
moves I don't recall very hard to get we
should not ask briad
Rapport and Bishop F6 six plate what do
you do Bishop
F4 Bishop F4 clearly black will keep on
hitting that Knight on E5 with rookie
eight you cannot tolerate the the Knight
and if Knight C6 play is
tempting yeah but I'm not sure you
really want to jump immediately Magnus
is also taking his time he would love to
keep the
tension first Big Thing by the world
champion falls behind on the clock
things were looking easy but yuang y
it's a tough customer not going to go
down without a
fight yeah after all he has some Harmony
in his pieces yeah white is spawn up we
don't really understand why y has really
sacrificed that
pawn why is Magnus taking so much of his
time yeah go Bishop F4 see what
happens yeah but something he
dislikes is it somewhere like Queen E8
and against Knight C6 then going Knight
B6 eventually setting up some Knight
takes D5 trick okay Knight C6 on the
board he goes Knight C6 directly all
right and another the big question do
you go queen8 and try to set up that
tactics that I've been mentioning
targeting the C6 Knight or do you go
Queen C8 but that looks way too passive
or you just eliminate it
immediately problem is with Queen E8 and
then you try to Target it you can never
take twice on C6 because Bishop F3 will
be there so Yu Yang y does take directly
goes Knight B6 still Pawn down but he
has some jumps Knight to
F5 yeah targeting opening up the look at
this now he can gain the pawn by taking
on C3 and then capturing on D5 yeah he
should wow so why did magnos really let
this happen takes takes Queen takes D5
doesn't look so bad for black at all
no and it's on the board
but why with the
Knight but why with the Knight I'm very
surprised Queen takes D5 was so much
more cleaner
agreed and yeah the engine agrees too
says Knight takes D5
X yeah but okay how do you protect the
pawn queen C2 will be met by Queen F6
probably that's what but Queen
d33 the move exactly that's the
problem Magnus thinking oh no he's gone
Bishop to F3 it looks like doesn't try
to defend the pawn yeah wow he can
really do this yeah he's trying to wow
Knight Tak CC Queen C2 and then it's
double attack Queen F6 Bishop B2 with a
pin Magnus would have won a piece that
was
fantastic so yeah he goes back now
what's going on white has the Bishops
slightly shaky Pawn structure but nice
Bishops yeah this is this is horrible
position for black the pawn on C7 is
very strong the pawn on C6 is a monster
I'm expecting some Queen D4 Rook D1
putting the pressure no Magnus takes
going for the end game black take with a
queen C takes the the C7 so Queen takes
and he will want to
capture yeah look have d one but there
is a big
towish potential in the position with
Knight C4 Rook C targeting that C6 Pawn
is Magnus really believing that okay Y
is done to 20 seconds that's the
problem Magnus is
believing Rook a d8 yeah making sure
that the Knight is still controlling the
A4
break
yeah it looks like he's let it get away
but no now black has D5 Rook D6 ideas as
well how do you keep keep
pressure yeah D D5
A4 if Knight takes what's the point then
then C4 ah C4 and Rook D1 beautiful Rook
D tricked
him Rook D1 Rook D Rook D1 rook d8 and
it's over Knight B6 okay Knight B6 but
then Rook B8 probably that will be the
key is it really working or yeah he just
goes Bishop
B7 then if Knight B6 Rook A6 so y tries
to run with his Pawn C3 I can't count C8
doesn't look like black is fast enough
no no yeah not at all with the bishop
and The Rook combo white Bishop is
coming back okay B4 only chance does
this
work I know still asking some questions
Rook takes A4 C2 Rook A1 B3 so he can't
take goes Bishop F5 Knight C5 but now
Rook A5 he's time yeah yeah it should be
over yeah also black black has a problem
with the back rank as well
yes this is it G6 he takes and The Rook
is in time to be joined by the king
stopping all the pawns and game over Y
young he does not look happy
resides wow what a what a game there was
a small Miss by Magnus but then
immediately he corrected he used
capitalized on Yan's mistake
all right we are jumping to the next
game what's in store for us in dud